when you're just wandering around with
no purpose with nothing to do that's
usually when you get in trouble
someone's curious if you've ever been in
trouble with the law I've been smoking
in the car all day long and sure enough
lights start flashing in the rear view
mirror and I'm like I am done I was an
entirely different person but where I
had a huge fear was stepping over the
line to posting videos on YouTube If I
gain the Applause of the crowds but I
lose the love and respect to my children
I believe I've failed
welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean this is gonna be a fun episode
because the team sent in some questions
they're Anonymous they're kind of
personal and they're gonna be fun are
you are you ready for this I have no
idea what to expect but I am here for it
uh basically I just I asked the team uh
how many how many people do we have on
the team now I think we have 16 W-2
employees and like eight contractors
amazing so uh yeah I just said hey we
are doing a podcast episode ask Sean
anything and we got some really cool
questions I wanna we'll start off a
little easy the the first question and
these just kind of range but if you
could have any superpower what would it
be and why if I could have any super
power it would be unlimited energy I
think I love doing what I do and now I'm
39 though as I approach 40 I'm noticing
that I do not have the same energy I did
in my 20s I've been dealing with some
you know kind of like health challenges
in terms of pain in my arms and hands
and so I think that's the Allure of the
the superheroons is there an
amplification of the limitations of our
human bodies and so uh if I just had
it's not even fancy if I just had the
energy to just do everything I want to
do every day non-stop but I also am
grateful for rest you know because just
meaning that like if if I if you never
got tired I don't know if that'd be a
life of the right rhythms because rest
is cool in margin but so this is a good
follow-up to the next one which is if
you weren't doing YouTube What Would you
be if you could do anything you know
what would you be doing if it wasn't
YouTube if I wasn't doing YouTube
I would
probably want to work in uh advertising
um maybe like I think about Mad Men or I
think about working in an advertising
agency of some kind being able to work
on Creative brand campaigns
um I think also maybe which I do this I
guess I do more than YouTube I speak now
I could see being like a professional
speaker or if you speak for a living
like write books and speak for a living
which you could argue I I do in a way do
that but but I'd maybe do that full-time
like somebody that travels and speaks or
is like a speaker yeah this is uh
another question which is have you ever
had a fear of public speaking or being
on camera I think I've always had some
level of confidence for communication
publicly we're in a small youth group
that's kind of where I got my start in
video and in some public speaking in
Marysville Washington but where I had a
huge fear was stepping over the line to
posting videos on YouTube meaning
putting yourself out there I had a fear
of other people's opinions fear of being
judged fear of not being good enough
fear of so in a smaller context I think
I it kind of came naturally but it puts
yourself on the internet context for
sure I had a lot of fear so if you
weren't on YouTube like you couldn't
choose YouTube as a platform what social
media platform would you pick like I
think just to be on like you know yeah I
mean I still probably would go at this
point I'd probably go Instagram
um because it you can't express yourself
in a lot of different ways there because
you got stories you could have still
still pictures and carousels it's a lot
of different storytelling
um as well as lives and videos and reels
so
it's more than anywhere else and and
yeah Facebook is Facebook and Tick Tock
kind of is different it doesn't have
those features so Instagram seems to be
the place where you could express
creativity and socially I feel like I'm
I'm pretty well connected there that's
where I like to hang out
I don't know who asked this but
someone's curious if you've ever been in
trouble with the law
uh I want to hear a good story here okay
so I want to say I I've never been in
trouble with the lock I don't have a
record
um I do remember once you know I was
really in weed in high school and of
course 420 is if you don't know the math
four people put five on that's the song
I got five on it you put five dollars on
a 20 sack of weed
and uh so 4 20 at 4 P.M you get a 20 SEC
4 P.M every day for people to smoke weed
all the time and then the holiday
everyone goes crazy so it's 4 20. I'm in
Washington it's fast and furious era I
got my Honda Civic I got my you know my
short shifter my subwoofers and like I'm
driving around visiting friends or
whatever and I'm like smoking weed all
day when I'm driving disclaimer this is
not condoned nor recommended and this is
illegal uh and this is driving under the
influence and um and so what was
fascinating though was okay it was like
a long day and I was like pretty tired
and I pick I picked some friends up
in the evening
uh my friend Skyler and then I'm with my
friend Aaron and so I've been smoking in
the car all day long you know and this
is like before Vapes and stuff existed
so it's like a pretty pungent type of
whatever
so I pick I pick up the homies and we
start driving and sure enough some
lights start flashing in the rear view
mirror and I'm like I am done and like
in the vehicle I want to say like in the
side console of the door is like
two three rolled joints like just in the
side of the door and then in the trunk
is like this box full of all kinds of
different paraphernalia and like
marijuana whatever and then one of the
guys I'm wrong with like dealing at the
time and he's got like a critical amount
of Due Time amount of you know and and
these days marijuana is legalized in
some states uh even record relationally
but not then
and and so what what's his true story
right
but but our friends in the back and he
brought with him like a Slurpee that had
alcohol in it and we're all underage of
course as well we're not and we're not I
think I might have been 18 but I'm not
21 or whatever I'm I might have been 17.
so a cop rolls up and he literally gets
me out of the car and he uh he's talking
to me behind the car and he's like
he's like I'm gonna take you in now or
whatever and then I go and then it was
something like unless you let me search
the car and I was like listen sir I'll
let you search the car but only under my
supervision or something like that or if
I do it with you and he's like okay
so he searches the car and my friends
get out the they're they're waiting and
uh I think what happened oh that's what
he he looked in schuyler's in the back
seat
and he goes what's in that cup sir and
then he smelled it so Skyler got caught
that he figured out there's alcohol in
his cup and then he's like what else do
you guys have and I was like listen
nothing but if you search the car so he
searched the car and what was so wild
was I was like watching the flashlight
and I think he was just like looking for
like a case of beer or like alcohol of
some kind and somehow I don't know if
you could apply God's grace to this
situation because
I don't think that's how it works but uh
he he flashlight all through the side
things whatever it may be looked like
because there was like trash in the door
too and you open up the back and there
was no cases of beer or alcohol or
anything else besides what was in that
slurpee cup so poor Skyler I don't know
if it's poor Justice served they called
his parents sure and uh he got picked up
so he wasn't able to keep going with us
and then they let us just drive off the
hook and so so I think there was moments
like that where you know it would have
maybe been slightly life altering
especially if you know we all got
associated with like trafficking or
something and so I do look back in
moments like that where I say it is it
is only by God's grace where I've made a
ton of mistake mistakes in my life I've
messed up a lot and I know first you
know switch up a few things and I could
have been on a different path or could
have gone down a different Road and I'm
grateful that I have learned learned
from and steered down a different path
so that's that's one of the at what kind
of age would you see kind of like
shifted from you know some of the some
of that doing that kind of stuff to even
I know you were working at Red Robin
before think media was built but like
was it a slow shift over time that kind
of just little things happen I know you
started working at a church like yeah
like there was a it was there was a
dramatic shift so you know from there I
got expelled from Christian High School
for uh partying and also for being in a
pornographic video with three girls So
that's its own story uh and I'm on a
pretty down you know
like a pretty Wildlife as you can it
sounds like but then I get expelled and
it gets worse I go to Community College
um to finish out my um uh my like high
school and I get into hard like Rave
drugs I started getting into like the
Rave scene so ecstasy and uh and I can
still count because I'll run into some
people I think I could count on two
hands I've done ecstasy less than 10
times probably or something like that
hippie flipped a couple times where you
can buy an ecstasy of mushrooms and some
different things like that so you know I
don't know Joe Rogan and I could
probably connect about some things on
the podcast someday uh and so but there
was one night that things was really a
turning point and you could almost call
it like a rock bottom and it was a night
where I just was partying too many
nights in a row which really messes with
your serotonin if you're taking MDMA
your serotonin is exhausted so now
you're just kind of on like the crack
that it's cut with meaning like the
speed or however because these are like
street drugs it's not like regulated uh
I never did crack but like it's kind of
like speed and so I'm really kind of in
this I take like three pills in a night
we lose our friend Brian he he took like
eight pills he's a dealer this is is
this is also who you're hanging out with
I had found myself into a a quite a
precarious circle of friends right and
uh we were up all night and then one of
the worst places to be in life is a rave
at like 3 4 5 a.m in the morning when
everyone's coming down like it's pretty
dark it went from like a little you know
I wanna swing from the chandelier that
song's about alcohol isn't it whoever's
saying that and uh alcohol addiction and
ultimately I'm way like you're coming
down you're kind of depressed you're
tired the the drugs are wearing off and
we lost our friend bro he we lost him in
the city he he was gone like like and so
our ride was gone and I was with my
girlfriend at the time
and so we hitched a ride with strangers
very generous of them to take us and we
ended up at this house in Edmonds
and it's six or seven a.m in the morning
and I'm we're around all these people
that kind of have like this gang banger
Edge to them there's like weapons
cocaine
hip-hop music blasting it is 6 30 a.m in
Edmonds Washington as well like out of
all places and like the party is just
getting started and so I'm sitting there
with my girlfriend at the time having
done drugs multiple days in a row but
they're all worn off and I'm in a
probably an overly extreme kind of
depressive situation but I'm so grateful
for it because I remember that exact
moment and as I'm observing my
surroundings I think to myself
I maybe have made a few wrong turns in
my life like the word I maybe made a few
decisions how is it like the morning the
sun is rising and there's like bullets
on the table and people are doing coke
and like this is like where even am I in
the morning so we actually uh we leave
and we start walking the streets of
Edmonds and I'm all I'm in a horrible
spot I'm treating my girlfriend really
bad because I'm like like yelling at her
and I like hate myself I'm like mad at
her I'm just mad at everybody I'm like
where what are what are we even doing
you know like why is this happening like
breaking down and that it messes with
your emotions well and here's what's
Wild
I actually had to go to Red Robin that
day and do a double shift and I remember
I went I had to go to work I still
showed up I popped another ecstasy pill
just to get through work at that point
you're just riding off the Speed my eyes
were all yellow and I remember team
members I looked jaundice and they were
like are you okay dog like you you look
like you're going through some stuff so
when you call it Rock Bottom I think I
just put my body under such severe
multiple days in a row that as soon as
that shift got down I like went home and
crashed and I went into like a multi-day
depression and it was during that time
and I believe that God works in
mysterious ways and and sometimes he
needs to get our attention and he needs
we need to be receptive and and when
when maybe life is going good and you're
living that life and you're just having
a lot of fun you're not receptive but I
was in a very receptive place because
I'm kind of like man I've seen the dark
side of this stuff kind of and like this
has led me to it all started as fun and
games but this is like the result of of
playing this life out to the extreme
kind of and I remember my stepdad
mentioned to my mom like hey what if you
want to see if Sean wants to go to
Prairie Bible Institute which is this
tiny school in
Alberta Canada one hour out of Calgary
Three Hills Alberta no one knows about
this place it's like 3 000 people live
in this small town in the middle of the
tundra and in the winter there's snow
all around you and ice and
um like 2 000 people in the school are
are uh the students of this small Bible
College and I would have never gone
there before but they brought it up and
as soon as they said it my mom it was my
stepdad's idea told my mom I was like I
want to go I was like sign me up and and
my thinking was it wasn't even that I
wanted to really go study the Bible or
even really pursue God but like the
little bit of wisdom was I need to like
change my surroundings I need to get out
of a cycle that I was in I need to do
something different change my location
and that changed everything for me
because then I went there
um I took Old Testament and New
Testament and I had been kind of
casually in church with my family but
then I started to see in scripture for
real I'm like oh man there's all these
prophecies written thousands before of
years before Jesus existed that are true
so I started to build the building
blocks up of my faith be transformed by
the word of God started to like really
develop a relationship with God and and
heal from a lot of things because a lot
of times a lifestyle like that comes out
of emotional pain or you know just
different ways you're dealing with or
seeking what you ultimately want you
know in life and what we were designed
for and I believe we were designed for a
relationship with God so all I have to
say is is um it was it was pretty
dramatic you know I had a few things
here and there like when I came on
Christmas break from I like quote
unquote relapse at a crazy level on
Christmas break from Bible College uh
but that was the big turning point and
um and then I came back got plugged into
church and the reason I did and that's
when I got into video was I I loved all
my friends I still wanted to connect
with them as much as possible but I knew
that my own self-discipline and
self-control was not high enough the
reason I knew that was because I was on
Christmas break I went to hang out with
my friends they're passing a blunt
around the circle and I remember the
first time it came by I was like no
thanks I'm good I'm on a different path
the second time I it came by I was like
no listen I can you know puff puff pass
I was like no I'm good I shouldn't third
time no fourth time I was like all right
dog dude faster you know and so I kind
of realized like what Circle are you
sitting here you know and I was like so
that like I couldn't sit in that Circle
and actually be committed to my values
and decisions like to stay committed to
the values and the life I wanted to live
I just had to be selective so I
committed to intern at the church where
I met Jeff Morris who got me into video
sight unseen I it wasn't that I knew
anything about the youth group or that
that was my vision it was actually I
just learned about a story in the Bible
King David when he got in trouble with
Bathsheba and ended up sleeping with
somebody that wasn't his wife and it
caused a whole bunch of other trouble
was because he should have been at war
in the summer when kings go to war he
was just chilling at home wandering on
the balcony when you're just wandering
around with no purpose with nothing to
do that's usually when you get in
trouble so I was like I'm gonna intern
I'm gonna work in Red Robin I'm gonna
stay busy and and then if you know I can
hang with my friends hey you come to me
hey come meet me at church hey let's do
this I wanted to stay busy enough that I
didn't just have margin in my schedule
to get into trouble if you will which
was a good decision and then from there
that's the dominoes of getting into
video and getting more disciplined and
getting into a different cycle well I'm
glad you kind of share that because a
lot of people I think just look at
successful people and and what you know
what you've built with think media and
they think I think you know I I think I
do this a lot I'm like they just have it
all together just always been this way
so it's interesting to hear some of that
those early stages stories that you know
have developed into why I think you make
a lot of the decisions and the way that
you are
um one of the questions that came in was
how do you stay motivated and productive
in your work
um and so can you can you share a little
bit about that yeah so I think uh what's
also what's interesting about that is as
I went to Bible College back then I was
an entirely different person I was not
motivated I did not have Vision I did
not have a picture vision is a picture
of a preferred future I didn't have that
vision and so you know where there is no
vision the people perish where there's
no vision that people cast off
discipline so we don't have discipline
and motivation if we don't have Vision
so I think capturing vision is the
source of my motivation furthermore that
I'm quoting a verse in Proverbs when I
say where there is no vision that people
perish you know the Old Testament was
written in Hebrew and the Hebrew word
for vision there it actually means
prophetic Vision it means vision from
God so I'm very passionate about the
Bible having principles that anybody can
use from any faith any background
um but there's a limit to that the
ultimate life hack
is a relationship with Jesus Christ like
the ultimate like success principle is
actually having a relationship with the
Creator because I've learned like you
can actually apply the principles of the
Bible and never know the person of Jesus
and they are still successful in fact
that's if you look around at anybody who
builds true and Lasting success and has
things like you can have integrity and
all this kind of stuff that's all in the
Bible it's always been there
but Vision that comes from God is I
think that's when
you have an Unstoppable fire it doesn't
mean you don't get discouraged it
doesn't mean you don't go through Dark
Nights of the soul but it's not just a
good idea it's a god idea it's not just
so in that season I plug in a youth
ministry I plug into this school of
ministry Arts is what it was called as
like a local Ministry School I study the
the Bible even more I start getting
around a real Biblical foundation and
start to develop a relationship with the
Holy Spirit and and uh and my
understanding the word and prayer and I
build up that real Foundation when you
ask how do I stay motivated that's the
fire I mean I think it's a fire that the
Christian has and should have it's the
Holy Spirit you know this is our beliefs
and what we know we are the temple of
God now the God's spirit lives inside of
us quickens our mortal bodies because of
what Jesus did on the cross we can reign
in life and so it's cultivating that
fire Paul told Timothy's like do not
neglect the gift that you have by laying
out of hands but like fan it into flame
so I think it's number one knowing that
there's actually an internal impartation
for me it was capturing the vision of
why do I ultimately want to do what
we're doing today it actually is to see
uh people discover that there's a God
who loves them and to see God's kingdom
Advanced and I think that business is
not just a good idea it's God's idea it
provides for our families it it empowers
people it employs people but I hope that
I think media macro my vision is that it
would be used to ultimately be a city on
a hill that people see us shining and
ultimately give glory to God and so
that is there's this inner thing that's
a lot deeper than views a lot deeper
than money it's a lot deeper than all
that stuff
and so it's that is the The Source it's
that vision
but then I have to fight for it and
protect it that's how I stay motivated I
learned I think from Jim Rohn
he said uh motivation is kind of like
taking a shower you need to take a
shower every day or you start to stink
you need to invest and get your
motivation every day or your attitude
will start to stink so you can't be
passive about the habits that maintain
motivation so for me it's like reading
prayer the word exercise breathing
eating well sleeping well if I start to
lose motivation I probably I start to do
like a diagnostic am I tired I should
probably rest
um how have I been eating I've been
eating out a lot eating a lot of
desserts and stuff I should probably
clean up my diet I just go back to those
practical things and a lot of times if I
do what I can control I find that now
reverse it if you eat poorly six days in
a row you feel horrible on the seventh
if you eat healthy and have good rest
and you stay hydrated six days in a row
you feel good on the seventh so so
there's like a real practical side and
then like a real spiritual side to to it
and and then it also goes into you know
part of my faith is belief in commitment
in a local church you know a lot of
people like to say you know I'm
self-made I'm like I'm not dude I'm God
made man I did it on my own I didn't I
mean not only is this a team thing at
think media but the team thing is a
local church it's being connected to
those who are planted in the house of
God will flourish and so
um I I tried I have studied and pursued
what are the habits and routines and
lifestyles of somebody that maintains
motivation guards their soul ex
experiences success and success really
isn't a mystery because if you can
figure out what those habits routines
and lifestyles are the hard part is
implementing it but then just commit to
those practices that's kind of how we've
tried to build our life is build it on
the the principles you can discover in
the Bible and uh and then live that way
and therefore I have had sustained
motivation and for what it's worth I
suppose that maybe ever since around
2003 4-5 you know we're going on 17
years of a pretty consistent setbacks
you know definitely some detours
definitely some Seasons that have been
tough and where I've lost ground but the
overall pattern has been like a long
obedience in the same direction and just
this steady uphill climb I think because
of living this life I think you know you
well it reminds me of is earlier you're
talking about how that moment when
you're in the car there's bullets
there's drug there's like you're like
whoa how did I get here it was a it was
actually a slow progress to this point
where you opened your eyes and I think
it's it seems to be at least for you
true in the opposite direction that you
know a lot of people have that moment
where now they're going in a different
direction but it's still a slow progress
over time and then you open your eyes
and you're like
we there's this company there's this
team there's this and so I find that
interesting that it works both ways it's
um it's uh I I love what you said there
about One Direction slowly over time
another just talking about Vision too
someone is curious if you can expand on
some of the future goals and vision for
think media yeah so uh our think media's
Vision ultimately think media's vision
um is to teach
business and marketing principles
from the Bible and that might sound
funny because we're really getting
spiritual in this episode but we
typically don't go here
um I think it just goes back to where
else would we get them you know what I
mean it's like would you get them from
just a good idea something that's just
worked in the last two years it goes
back to that thinking and when I say
business and marketing they'd be like
don't you teach video If you really
take it back we are communication won't
go away business won't go away the need
to Market and get your message out there
won't go away so vision is something you
want to be bigger than just what it is
you're doing today I don't see YouTube
going anywhere in 10 years YouTube could
be here for 20 30 years maybe it's going
to be a 100 year old company but if our
if our vision contained the word YouTube
our vision would be too small
so that's why our vision is okay how you
know and and I'm kind of butchering it
but that's that's it's a more expansive
type of a thing so saying that that's
where you and I were talking about
not just the think media channel where
we talk about YouTube and video but what
if we had to think social media like
could we have other channels
interestingly enough in terms of the uh
different vision and picture we have
growing up as I'm driving around on 420
listening to Wu-Tang I've always been
inspired by the Wu-Tang Clan because
they were nine individual artists that
teamed up uh to build one strong brand
that ultimately promoted their
individual projects though and many of
them probably would have been successful
on their own but the Wu-Tang has built
such a bigger brand than any one of them
could have built on their own
and so that's partly what we're trying
to do here at think media I think what
we understand is yes YouTube is the main
thing and video is the main thing but
with our brand can we bring on other
content creators
um can we launch Future YouTube channels
and then we are also self-aware that we
are an education company and so that
would mean books videos courses events
and all of that can expand I see no no
limit to it I also want to create a
vision big enough that remarkable people
like you and other think team members
your vision could live inside it so long
as uh you want to be a part of what
we're doing and so you had even
mentioned a passion for filmmaking
there's been many people who a few that
have had that same passion I think media
and so I also am like I don't fully know
what it's all going to look like but I
do think that we
um especially I've always wanted to have
money for the mission and I've always
wanted to have be able to fund art so
just in the next couple of years like
maybe we do make a documentary and it's
it gets distributed on YouTube or it's
paid on Amazon Prime Netflix so for sure
in media for sure and creativity and
that's maybe like we see a super bright
future in the Creator economy
if I Niche down
um our current Mission we say help 10
000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference on YouTube and
again the difference between mission and
vision the mission is like a measurable
Target that we're working on right now
it's something we could reach it
wouldn't be bad then we up level it and
so we are tracking that in monday.com
and our slack thread and the silver play
button pictures and all the stuff we're
getting so we're obsessed with that
mission at this moment but we've also
expanded that recently where to
summarize the phrase we're on a mission
to double the crater economy so we're an
education company teaching people a set
of skills
that's also kind of a wider Mission
because it'll always be bigger if the
crater economy is 50 million content
creators now we're trying to make it 100
because there's no we're so excited
about there's no better way to be able
to express yourself work from home honor
your family work with your kids design
your own path it's a very exciting
industry so on a mission to double the
Creator economy and in the near term
um I I do feel like we're called to do
events we've done growth video live five
times we're taking a break in 2023 but
to be hosting an event
um to have a coaching program we are
going to be launching a mastermind
future courses more videos more channels
more of the same and uh and then again
lastly I mentioned it but maybe what
I've learned from ministry that's what I
see in the Bible what I see from other
teams I I think a good leader amplifies
those around them and a good leader is
not a dictator
so
I also
hope that uh I I try to be inclusive in
the shaping of the vision I understand
that someone leads the charge someone
does have to maybe have the final say
and make decisions but a question rather
than hey Sean where do you want to go my
question to the think media team is is
where do you want to go where do we want
to go together and knowing that maybe I
still would be that final decision maker
Sony and I are the founders of the
company we want to have big ears and
open let I think that the the best ideas
or clarity about our future is a
community thing I'm trying to create a
community thing and not a dictatorship
if you will and so we're still seeing
how that goes it's pretty wild how early
we still are it's amazing what we're
experiencing
um and and uh but this industry is so
wild that I have heard some people say
it's good to have a one five ten year
vision and in certain areas of life we
do as we especially as we think about
kids and where are they going to grow up
or go to school or preschool or
homeschool and all this kind of stuff we
have those kind of things but the crater
economy is so wild it's like four
minutes ago AI comes out out chat GPT
comes out and now like the whole world's
flipped upside down like it's like
people saying this is going to change
everything and that's probably not an
understatement
so if you're making an unflexible
10-year plan forget that even a one-year
plan there's so much stuff happening in
this industry that I think there almost
needs to be you want to have like that
kind of core you don't want to just be
blown around by Trends but you gotta
have a willingness to like switch things
up in real time and so we're kind of
pulling on both
Parts trying to figure it out as we go
no it's awesome
um so we and this kind of is uh so we
had some questions come in about money
yeah and so I wanted to run a few of
these by you someone asked if you invest
your money and what and where are you
investing
um and then could you follow that up
with some uh it just ties with it some
lessons you've learned about investing
and Building Wealth I'm this is
something I'm learning that I personally
need to get educated on and I need to
continually get educated on a book that
did change my life was Rich Dad Poor Dad
around 2007 changed my thinking and that
was initially the first thing I focused
on I don't think this is it's definitely
not right for everybody you got to carve
your own path but I went all in on
basically one thing which is kind of
like betting the whole Farm we did not I
would say that Sony and I I don't think
we invested in retirement until the last
two years I'm 39 we started we started
retirement when I was 37. ish maybe 36
but that would have been the earliest we
and we are now incredibly blessed we've
been blessed for a while at think media
but the last two three years things got
remarkable prior to that it was like
this is it this is like all we got and
so that was sort of the idea and that
model would be the start your own
business model we started our own
business and that
um I think that the solopreneur side
hustle thing actually is something that
every single person listening to this
should invest in the idea of building
like a team that's pretty complex with
like an HR department and PLS and P L's
and all this other stuff
I don't know if every I don't I actually
not everybody is is called to probably
be the Principal person the lead person
doing that they should maybe link up
with somebody else so
um I was less wired of like
not thinking about 401k or stocks or
even IRAs or whatever like we've
probably been doing those only the last
five years and and the problem with that
is the sooner you start investing
there's just so many if you if you start
early and you just compound like even
your age like you're set right you know
what I mean like if you just stick with
what where we're literally talking about
maybe I was 10 years Plus past when
you're maybe thinking about some basic
Roth IRA among other things but the cool
thing was I bet the whole farm and Sony
and I and it's it was cool to see what
happened
um now we are thinking about defined
benefit plans is is one thing that we're
doing is it which is a a good tax it's a
tax savings any real estate Investments
that is like that you guys real estate
wise we've been getting really educated
was simply we have we just bought a
house in Vegas and a house in Washington
and the real estate investment in
Washington was Airbnb the first value
was family so we could be up there now
that we have a couple kids but then
there was a couple other things at the
time interest rates were low we found a
house off Market we found a good deal we
got it going but we set it up as an
Airbnb and we learned that if you
materially operate it meaning that you
manage it yourself you can get a a
benefit of what a real estate
professional gets of accelerated
depreciation or bonus depreciation so
that was also that's a huge tax savings
plus it earns income plus
um uh different write-offs and things
and so which as your business is
profitable that becomes a whole I would
one of my biggest education is probably
taxes because of people like Ryan Pineda
and Matt Bontrager and now being a part
of masterminds and stuff no matter who
you are one of the biggest bills you
wherever you will ever pay is taxes
so people are like oh my biggest bill is
my mortgage my biggest bill is that like
for a lot of people you're paying 20 to
25 of your income to taxes and then as
for a business owner like oh the
business no business owners do too like
everybody is and as you go up you're
paying 37 percent uh at the highest tax
brackets if you're living in California
and you have a couple other taxes you
know guys like Graham Stefan would say
if you're living in California with a
Biz like his you're paying 50 or more in
taxes
so learning about
legitimate write-offs and all that
that's a huge one and and I would Point
people towards the three-part series we
did with Matt Bontrager here on the
think media podcast for that topic
um and so yeah we're looking at real
estate but one of the biggest things and
I've got this advice and maybe I'm just
really understanding it now
is uh my friend Pedro said this he's
like don't let the Tail Wag the Dog
and he said like at the end of the year
people start thinking about write-offs
and they start thinking about like okay
if I buy a six thousand pound vehicle I
can write the whole thing off this year
and and then I get like 30 off of it and
you're like yeah but if it was 100 Grand
you still spent 77 000 you didn't even
need the vehicle did you even need the
vehicle and if you wanted it still did
you even need it and and then there's
all kinds of like loopholes and I heard
Alex from Ozzy say this as well you got
to protect your focus and so as I get
into real estate I'm looking for more
passive syndications and things like
that because the greatest thing I can
control is focusing on think the
greatest thing I control is focusing on
think and then focusing on recovery and
rest and so getting too distracted and
something I don't know but in the
meantime I'm still chipping away at
stocks or chipping away at education I
do want to get into like
dividend stocks to have a little cash
flow there and uh and I'm trying to just
continue to up my education and get
around smart people and so Sony is also
a big expert and she's our
Chief Financial Officer of think media
and thank God for her she manages she
managed our checkbook When We Were Young
broke 21 newly married she was the CFO
of our you know 30 grand a year Empire
and now she's the CFO of a multi-million
dollar company and people who scrutinize
our books from The Outsider like this is
insane her attention to detail and and
different things so we are definitely
being thoughtful and then back to that
it goes into things like we like to
reinvest when you talk about what do you
invest in I mean we took
our team to Disney last year
and why spouses and kids so one it's a
business trip but when I think about
investing I want to reinvest in my
business reinvest in our people reinvest
in a lot most of the time you say hey we
need this computer you and Kyle you know
and I'm like well mainly Kyle
because 18 monitors in his uh he has a
monitor dedicated to slack like it's
just this vertical I'm like you need a
slack monitor uh and ultimately like uh
when I think about uh investing in if
it'll help us go faster reinvest in the
business and that's and that's why like
if we want a car or whatever but who
cares about this stupid car but like if
it's a computer internet speed build out
the studio get the camera get the lenses
trying to think about raises and I'm
asking again I'm asking how can uh what
is the pathway for people who work at
think media to become millionaires and
what are the vehicles we can install in
terms of how do we build
whether that's investing or building a
fund where we get equity in Brands and
all the above and as people get raises
and as they also as we bring that's one
of my Visions too just bring Financial
education into think so that people are
uh because it's not just the money you
make it's also how you invest it and
maybe having different vehicles and
opportunities and asking the question of
what does Private Equity look like and
how do we do different things like that
so obviously Investments can be you know
risky and I just remember when I came on
growth video one was a big investment
that you guys made into the business but
the question is what's the riskiest
business move you've ever made
and what was the outcome
yeah well that's that's probably the
answer because first in when you we met
or right around the time we met you came
and kind of where the vlogger
documentarian of growth video live one
and that was a six-figure investment and
so it costs not just for for me to film
uh and and
um yeah so it was a big one so that was
100 Grand and at the time it was super
scary and that's a lot of money no
matter how you slice it but that was the
hotel and the cost and and everything
else to pull off our first ever event
and and the video which we can link it's
definitely where it's kind of a cool
piece of history and there's a lot of
nuggets in it we'll put it in the show
notes is um risking a hundred thousand
dollars in Vegas was like the title
because we were risking on that first
event what's funny is that is the risk I
think we compounded the most because
fast forward to
we take growth video to another level
it's the first year was in person we
didn't know if we were gonna do it the
second year and it was in person we
called it a one day it turned out to be
like a day and a half and the night
before so everything always that's a one
day for me is a three day and then the
pandemic happened so we were virtual two
years those were the leanest years and
arguably the most profitable profitable
because overhead is is so low I don't
even know if that's true but I mean at
least it's they're very low risk because
it's it's like running a virtual event
and then we swung for the fences
to hire Gary vaynerchuk to speak at his
full keynote fee at the time which has
gone up in 2022 and as we we knew it was
actually it was risking a lot of levels
we didn't really know if lockdowns would
be softened enough if people would
actually come we didn't really know
where covid was going to be at but by
the end of our second virtual event our
fourth year we made a couple decisions
we locked in Gary and we locked in I
think the M Hotel and so it was like all
in like back to taking a bet and so
Gary's like 155 000. so our first event
only cost six figures
his keynote fee cost more than our first
entire event in our first year of think
media proper we only made like a hundred
and sixty thousand dollars Top Line
basically we paid garyvee the business
the entire revenue of like every
contractor and like Sony and I living
off and in every expense and every
travel so it speaks to building up your
value and what a keynote speaker and and
while that actually for some people it
might be hard for them to digest it's
supply and demand it's his time and it's
the value that he brings because uh
definitely people love Gary and he's
he's known he's influential and and it
can lead to ticket sales having him
speak so that was just the first
decision what was so funny
and this is one of the things that was
the theme of the first event was one of
my mentors Brett Johnson he has a quote
and a tattoo that says scared money
don't make money so we've tried to learn
that at think media like you do have to
take risks they could be calculated
but scared money don't make money you
gotta you gotta reinvest in your
business you got to try something you
also got to be able to reinvest your
business even if you lose
because you it's not you don't invest
enough that it would destroy you yes
that would be too much risk but if you
make four Investments and two fail but
one does our right and one wins Big
scared money don't make money you had to
actually be willing to like it's okay to
lose sometimes you win sometimes you
learn and so
grow a video live
2020 too was by far the absolute
greatest stretch for us we'll link up in
the show notes a conversation that I did
with Chris do about that from the future
we broke down this entire it was about
an hour and a half conversation and I
went into all the metrics and analytics
of but on a macro that event ended up
costing us almost a million dollars it
was 917 thousand dollars that's not
counting paying the think media team or
human resources so
um with the time it took to set it up
and ramp into it now it also Not only
was it profitable on ticket sales
but it was also profitable because of
the offer we made so it was a risk that
paid off and then the dividends of the
brand and the reach and the the up level
because you went from a virtual event to
like an A1
top one percent of events in the world
at least in terms of the scope and the
scale and the speaker lineup Alex or
Mosey Patrick David Gary vaynerchuk it
was a major major stress uh stretch and
it came with a lot of stress and
pressure and I think that we at the
think media team might look back on it
and say we experienced a little bit of
trauma but no doubt about it I think
we'd also look back on it with Joy
saying when you also take calculated
risks and stretch yourself those are
your biggest seasons of growth they
change you they transform you you learn
a lot nothing ventured nothing gained no
pain no gain there was certainly pain in
pulling off event we were punching above
our weight class and one of the reasons
why we're taking a break this year
because people said you're crazy there's
so much momentum the brand is so strong
people loved it everyone who there
wanted to come back was our theme this
year is built to last not because we
couldn't have pulled it off this year we
could have but we learned that we need
an infrastructure specifically team
members that aren't just fully busy in
another department and we're all
rallying to try to pull something off
that's too heavy but to either shift the
org chart around hire the right people
and build an infrastructure that if
we're going to keep doing an event like
that that's in and of itself that's not
its own it would be its own small
business but like if we could have an
event that costs us a million dollars to
run and can bring in 1.2 to 1.5 or that
ranges in this one to three million
dollar range I see that as becoming its
own vertical back to like the vision
question
that should have it could have its own
staff or its own director its own and it
hasn't it's been like we're already
really busy and let's also throw an
event so the reason we're taking a year
off is to like get the infrastructure
around it healthy get it's basically
kind of get it optimized in its own
vertical with at least one or two three
staff members devoted to that and of
course we all rally around it but that
way it's not an unsustainable Pace to
try to keep running that event that's
really good the next question is more
personal yeah and it's what's your
biggest fear when it comes to Business
and Entrepreneurship I don't know if
anything comes to mind but just thinking
through
um through that question is there
something that comes to mind that
you want to share I mean my biggest fear
ultimately is
um
that I would
s experience success and lose my soul
and without being super spiritual about
it let's go more practical at the end of
my life I want the people closest to me
to love and respect me the most and at
the end of my life I want I don't want
if I gain the Applause of the crowds but
I lose the love and respect to my
children I believe I've failed so
actually
of course there's a I've got a ton of
emotions tied up in think media I've got
a ton of
I don't I I want things to go well here
but like
am I afraid of of if we have a good run
but if it was to quote unquote fail I'd
say no like I I'm I feel like I'm living
on I'm playing house money now like I
feel like I've already won I've already
exceeded
in terms of people maybe it was you said
uh we were sitting at the stake place
with the think media team two nights ago
herbs and Rye here in Vegas and I'm like
I'm 39 and you're like when you were 30
did you picture yourself sitting here
and I was like I didn't even know the
steakhouse existed so absolutely not I
did not you know
um but
I think I'm I'm already like wow look at
where we are and I just want to be I
want to Steward it more than anything I
just want to be faithful and from my
standpoint these are my core beliefs
that I've integrated it's kind of like
not my will but your will be done God
like if think be where does think media
go and just God what do you want next
because I think ultimately a life that
is successful but is successful without
God or his plan is not a successful life
so it's like if if I all of this is such
a blessing and it's so overwhelming like
I'm just so grateful to be here and to
have all this but I also
like to have the thought exercise is is
if this went away would I be okay so
where's my worth and my value is it in
is it in all this stuff that's happening
or is it in that like if this went away
of course I want to be able to like pay
the bills and whatnot but as Sony and I
are trying to be smart with our finances
like we're starting to hit moments where
we're like that part's taken care of so
then what what ultimately like and I
know that I would be very difficult
because I feed off of
sounds funny I I'm really not motivated
by money I'm business minded but like to
me it is about the the game the
significance the impact I love building
leaders I love the team I love the
community all the stuff that we're
building and it's about building I love
being a builder but I think you know I
think I heard garyvee say too he's like
what would happen if it was all torn
down you started from zero it'd be like
I don't know I'll just start building
again because if you're a builder or I
just build the next thing I just move on
so I think my so my greatest fear is
actually to have wild success but to
lose the things that matter most in the
process and that I'm self-aware enough
to know that that's actually where my
dark side would go
my me at the extreme
is
not investing in friendships or family
if I if I left my ambition unchecked
and I am careful I don't like I don't
agree with nor do I want to be
influenced by some there are people it
sounds funny it sounds funny maybe to
our podcast listeners or maybe it
doesn't there are some people who are
like f your family man like they're it's
fine but like it's all about money it's
all about business like you know your
wife's either on board or not dude you
got to just build just go for it like no
like it's a it's a team thing like it's
a marriage it's a covenant I think that
stems from it's kind of a selfish point
of view in the sense that because I've
heard you know clips and stuff and
um obviously I think you and I
it's an interesting conversation because
yeah it's like your your wife should
support uh you know what you're doing
and all these things and
um
sure but like at the cost of what you
know and I I I think I wanted I just
want you to talk a little bit more too
just even about you and Sonia and how
you guys work together because I think I
mean you guys support each other but I'm
sure like I know and you're talking
about already it's like you're not going
to building media at the cost of of your
marriage and and I think uh some people
you know maybe they wouldn't just say it
that way but they are like well find a
wife that supports your business and
yeah I I get that but I mean what would
you just say to like someone who wants
to build a YouTube channel they want to
get into entrepreneurship yeah and maybe
they're their wife or husband actually
isn't supportive of that yeah I don't
know if you have any advice there or no
it's a good question I think I think
that
like I believe
that marriage is for life I believe you
should do you should do whatever you can
to make marriage work I do believe that
there are reasons that marriage is
should end uh and that can be even you
know that's biblical in some cases but
for the most part if you've committed to
marriage what's interesting this is kind
of true about you and me as well
is and this would be a real dark path
but like we got married before any of
this existed Sony and I did we got
married at 21. so I need to honor
and like this is maybe a narrative you
see in a movie or something that's like
somebody has friends or family or people
with them when they had nothing and they
get something and they burn all those
bridges and I I there's men who do that
I mean there's probably like equal
opportunity but like like once because
why imagine this like okay now you have
money you have people sliding into your
DMs you have you like Fame just opened
every door for you and so it's it's the
guy who like is like cool like nobody
knew me no whatever but now like I could
get rid of these people because I I
could do this now and I mean to me that
is that would that's the darkest path
that you could possibly walk down and uh
and not only is it selfish but it's also
um you would be selling out for money or
sex or whatever and uh the opposite
being that
I think
for what's very interesting about our
marriage is
we have to grow together it would be a
whole different situation if I'd been
single for up until this point and I
would be in a different situation
of you know dating and what I'm looking
for in a spouse and so on and so forth
but I'm not only gonna uh honor my
marriage but I also believe God has
brought us together and then once you
make that commitment you make it work
and that's kind of my point if you're
listening to this and you're single I
think it's incredibly wise you have a
blank slate to think about okay what is
the what are the attributes what do I
see the vision as what do I want the
wiring you know we've had uh Alex for
Moses spoke at our our event and Layla
has been on the podcast and and they
talk about how like they both linked up
knowing they both were like we don't
want to do anything but work
we may not want to have kids
we want to work all the time and we're
unified in that and and like when the
timing of when they got together
whatever they seem like a really good
match
the flip side back to your question
ultimately and I think something that
again what if you don't have a spouse
that's supportive now well I think you
have to be empathetic to the fact that
like
this might be new so it's like you're
bringing up an entirely new thing you're
trying to go in an entirely New
Direction
and yes your spouse should change with
you and go with you but at the same time
like if you're switching up some of that
original stuff it's it is a conversation
it is an evolution
and I think it's it's kind of terrible
if you just go well I've made I've
become a new person I'm going a new
Direction and I'm leaving you behind
that's kind of cold you know and I think
that that what were your original vows
exactly and then I think you know for
the the spiritual listener I do think
that
prayer and patience can be a good
guidance this is what I've learned I
also really believe that if we
prayerfully are
and and practically pursuing the right
spouse that that person is actually a
compliment to you in a lot of ways that
you may not realize here's what I mean I
don't know if Sonia is the best partner
for me to help me grow to the maximum
speed of growth and maximum amount of
money and that is the biggest blessing
in the entire world because if it was an
inheritance gained too early in the
beginning won't be blessed in the end I
am like a hot air balloon that will just
endlessly fly higher and higher I'm like
Icarus I'll fly too close to the Sun and
my wings will melt Sonia is like some
weights so some people could say I feel
like my partner or my spouse is holding
you back maybe true or maybe they're
keeping you grounded and they're keeping
you and so I could be the unrealistic
dreamer and she lives in reality and so
again if if I was pure pedal to the
metal as we talked about my personality
is certainly a little bit addictive a
little bit a little bit extreme and so
it's nice to have therefore what could
seem frustrating if your spouse feels
like they're just kind of poking holes
in your YouTube Vision you shouldn't be
feeling like oh they're being so
negative that actually that's an
opportunity for them to be refining the
vision for there to be more
communication that could be leading you
to some better timing sure there may be
some situations where
it is very frustrating it could get
toxic we are not we're not uh therapists
and this is not counseling and we
recommend getting into into counseling
but for what it's worth from that
perspective again I think that
um you know you got married young as
well and so it's gonna be such an
evolution and I think that uh being in
communication letting it grow like us we
moved to Vegas that was hugely
disruptive in my life's life all of our
family though now that we have kids on
both sides are is in the Northwest Sonia
has sacrificed a ton for the last decade
Plus
she definitely felt called that we
should go here but it wasn't like her
first you know kind of choice so there
is that give and take and I do I think
marriage gets weird or Partnerships get
weird if you get super controlling and
super selfish and there's no give if
it's all just take and if you forget
where you came from and if you uh forget
who got you there and forget who helped
you build there and if you get arrogant
or prideful so as to think that well
cool you got me here but now I can go
alone and it's a sad story and
unfortunately uh it breaks my heart one
of the most speaking to men that men
that that that back out on their
families or back out on their spouses or
back out on their kids I have no respect
for that
um that uh you know and we're like okay
cool I'm glad you got us here but now
I'm gonna go do my own thing I'm gonna
do me no bro you shouldn't be doing you
you should be honoring your family and
uh yeah that's where I'm coming from and
I think people change over time so you
know it's like I want to start a YouTube
channel I want to start a business and I
think a lot of it too is is building
trust in the sense that's like if if I
go to Madeline and I'm like I want to
start this new thing it's like
she knows me better than I actually know
myself and you might just be is this
just another thing you're trying to
start and and and you're just not
self-aware and you're bitter and
frustrated because but you're actually
just always moving on to the next thing
and you're not just committed to one
thing so I think a lot of it too is like
you know be faithful with the small
stuff that you are given and maybe you
have a little bit of free time right now
and what are you doing in that free time
to actually keep your word of like when
so when you're like this I want to go
all in on this you know it actually
makes sense and it's not just like oh
this is another thing I think um you
know it's it's being self-aware and just
keeping ourselves even if if you're
single uh accountable to that you're
also gonna turn 40 here soon
I'm just curious as we wrap up your
thoughts coming into turning 40 and I
want to hear uh these next 10 years when
you turn 50
where where do you where do you want to
be just emotionally yeah physically
spiritual like what where do you see
yourself yeah you know I've been the the
top of Mind One is health because I will
if if I have one thing I would have
really done differently is I would have
paid more attention to my health from
like 20 to 32 because I have what like
repetitive strain injury repetitive
stress injury kind of like a carpal
tunnel some nerve stuff I'm actually
optimistic that it'll all get worked out
and I'm addressing it right now but it
was it's the result of overwork and then
maybe not even overwork but not working
out and doing the strength training and
different things in combination with it
and taking proper breaks
um speaking back to Compulsive and just
working so hard and again not
necessarily working out the strength of
the infrastructure so I am wanting to
get into the best shape of my life
between now my four 30th birthday and
also just live a healthier life on my
way to 50. I think that as I think about
this I I also think about 40s as as a
prime I feel like I'm 40 years Young on
November 6 this year
um and there's different people that say
like in your 20s you're kind of like
figuring the things out in your 30s
you're doing this thing in 40s and and
so I think I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about Legacy which would mean
like mentorship I want to Mentor leaders
success without a successor is failure
um I want to I want to be smarter I feel
like as I when as I turn 40 I've been
through enough pain and challenges and
business lessons and not not even enough
they're ongoing but that that you get
wisdom in terms of Seasons I've lived
through recessions you know like you're
like it's funny and you start thinking
like dude I sound like my parents but
you're like well it actually is that
experience and I would argue evaluated
experience like I have been evaluating
my experience I'm a of an avid journaler
and an avid Note Taker and I I document
things that are happening in my life
things that I'm praying about things
God's speaking to me things that I'm
seeing in the word and situations that
are happening because I do feel called
to write books and to teach and train
out of some of this deeper stuff so I
can see some of that happening in my 40s
I'm also now it's it's everyone's on a
different path but we're maybe a little
bit older with some young kids and we're
thinking about having more so we've got
you know a six month old and a two and a
half year old so now we're thinking
about school homeschool preschool and
and so when I'm 50 I'm going to have a
12 year old and a 10 year old at least
and so that's interesting and so
thinking about the family piece which is
a different pace I think it was God
works all things to the good we've
people that know our story we've had
health challenges my wife almost died so
we had kids laters later in life mainly
because of how that disrupted our life
that the part blessing of that though
was no kids until 37 meant
think media is where it is it meant that
I was able to focus on that to just
hustle work extra and even even the pain
in my arms or whatever I'm always like I
know I could have done it differently
but like
you can't have regrets I'm like it's
just the work you put in I I think about
it for like Sean Bradley and Legacy and
stuff I'm like you know
I want to be very empathetic comparing
computer labor to like physical labor
but it literally is is tears in the
muscle and tendon strain and different
things and I'm like it's kind of like
you know like Grandpa put in the word
like he really worked himself to the
Bone to set up the Next Generation so
I'm starting to like almost have that
mentality like how am I setting them up
I'm like yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
change it for that regard for like
laying the railroad track that hopefully
future Generations can drive on and
that's the dream it's not about I want
to build a a platform not so I can stand
on it but so others can stand on it and
and that my ceiling should be the next
generation's launching PAD as well as
just everyone who connects to think
media's launching pad so I'm thinking
about Legacy I'm thinking about health
I'm thinking about family and I'm
thinking about sustainability our theme
this Earth think media is built to last
we will have a new theme every a year
but that's these themes are not like
they come and then we reject them I feel
like they're building blocks and I'm
that's what I'm kind of thinking about
is how do we build to last not just for
a year but for decades and uh
that's that's sort of what my mindset is
I love that
um thank you for answering those
questions for being open and broken uh a
lot of good questions came in from the
team and you know we're I can speak on
just behalf I think media you know we're
grateful for you Sonia and just the team
and the culture you guys have built and
so I'm excited to just be a part of this
mission to help the Creator economy to
help people go full time and so it's
been uh fun so far I'm excited to just
keep going and if you haven't subscribed
to the think media podcast yet bro what
are you even doing hit the Subscribe
button click on the screen you guys can
watch another video and we'll see you in
the next one